hey y'all since in the heights is on its
way to theaters
we are going to talk about another
recent broadway theatrical adaptation
yeah that's right we're talking cats
it's the 2019 new
movie musical that is rotten at 19
on the tomato meter with a 53 audience
score
we have a very special guest today with
us angie han the deputy editor and
critic
at mashable who's going to give us a
little tease of what she thinks
of cats angie it's your cue lady is
rotten tomatoes wrong about
cats rotten tomatoes is limited in its
ability to convey the full
experience of cats via a single number
damn for the first time we're doing it
this way you are
kicking it off with style and with that
being said
brian let's cue the music
all right in just a moment we're gonna
break down how we feel about the film
and play some trivia but mark hello sir
glad to be back uh i have missed you
jacqueline so much we look i i did a few
shows without you
but luckily i didn't burn the place down
i didn't say anything too stupid and so
we're still
up and running and talking about this
movie look star wars movies are fun
mcu movies are fun this is my most
anticipated
episode of this podcast that we've ever
done yeah it's definitely gonna be
uh playing more in my wheelhouse but i'm
so interested to hear about what you
think about it but before we do that
go ahead and tell us a brief synopsis uh
if you can
of the movie cats so you got these cats
right that's it that's a synopsis just
stop right there you got these cats
right you get these cats and they like
singing and dancing and it's based on
the
smash hit broadway musical whose music
you could definitely hear in the ellis
household when i was growing up because
my mom and my sister
both accomplished piano players loved
playing this music and they were great
at it
and then they decided to make a movie
about it and it came out a couple years
ago too much fanfare and the film itself
features
a bunch of cats and they're all
competing for the honor of being this
one cat that gets to ascend to the next
level you got a bunch of jellicles and
they have the jellicle ball that's what
all the cats are
excited about and they don't know who's
gonna get nominated to do what
and then they eventually sing and dance
their way to a climax where we do find
out who gets to ascend
who gets left behind who gets their
heart broken
and there's a lot of singing there's a
lot of dancing there's a lot of
cgi some of it good some of it really
not good
and a whole lot of famous people thrown
into this movie
and it just all adds up to cats
that was pretty good that was really
good um
and i will tell a little bit story about
andrew lord weber describing
what he thought cats was when someone
tried to make it allegorical
um but before i do that i want to give a
big high to someone i haven't seen in a
while but who is also somewhat newly
returning
perducy lucy what's up man hey how you
guys doing
glad to have you back thank you um
so now that we have our crew back let's
go ahead and bring in our
certified guest um who we've already
teased um who
really came out the gate firing really
hot
angie welcome to the show i'm really
excited to have you here
a new newish la resident who i get to
chat movies with now
at the amc's when we when we can but
so you think rotten tomatoes can't
really convey
everything like i don't even want to try
and paraphrase what you said what did
you say about raw tomatoes what is it
i don't remember order for word but i
said rotten tomatoes is limited in its
ability to convey the full
experience of cats via a single number
uh because i feel like you know uh it
has a what a 19
and that could mean a lot of things
different things to different people and
i feel like you
if i saw a film had nineteen percent
most of the times i just play oh it's
probably just like
bad um and we can debate whether or not
this movie is bad but it's also just
kind of uh insane and really just swings
for the fences in a way that i don't
it's a love it or hater movie in a way
that i don't think the 19
really lets people know yeah
um it's kind of hard movie to even
describe which is why mark i'd give it
up for you
for even trying to attempt the synopsis
um
but this was your first viewing of cats
period like musical and theatrical what
what where are you feeling about it
um as far as this rotten tomatoes right
or wrong so i
i agree with angie in the sense that 19
of when i say a movie is nineteen
percent i
my first word that i would associate
with any film that low
that rotten is it's forgettable and
that is certainly not the case with cats
and
sometimes i feel like even if i didn't
like the movie
the effort and all of the the production
that went into this
the the care the tender and love
that went into making this movie i feel
like it should deserve more than 19
but if i'm just judging it on its merits
as a movie
i'm sorry i think rotten tomatoes is
pretty accurate here
okay um how do i say it so i think
rotten tomatoes is
right in the sense that the film sort of
deserves
a 19 however
however i
can't not tell people like my personal
feeling like more people should see this
movie
in the same way like i cannot say the
room is a good movie
but you have to see it because until you
see tommy wiseau
hump the air you cannot really
experience that and so yeah you really
you have to experience it and and it's
not that long ago but
thinking back to like the fact that i
went to london to do the junket for this
movie like there was so many things with
me in this movie that happened that we
will get into and i'm gonna need a
little trip back to what
was happening so thankfully we have mr
tim ryan our view
our review creation manager who's gonna
take us back to the time of cats with
our favorite segment
two minutes with tim brian cue us up
[Music]
you know every so often a movie will
come along that inspires normally
mild-mannered film critics to go
completely insane
in 2019 that movie was cats and a big
reason for that was
for so many cats was a singular
experience
it was seemingly unencumbered by the
usual notions of taste and sense and
plot that drives most other movies
in other words there's nothing quite
like cats
given that so many critics watch this
movie with slack-jawed fascination
the usual criteria for good or bad or
fresh or rotten
are a little skewed but let's go to the
numbers cats is rotten at 19
on the tomato meter with 326 reviews and
it's got a 53
audience score so what did the critics
have to say in a rotten review allison
wilmore of
new york magazine vulture wrote there is
something magical about the simple fact
that this movie exists in all its
obscene
absurd wonder it's terrible filmmaking
choices and bursts of
jaw-dropping talent however in a fresh
review angie han of mashable wrote
i gasped with laughter i covered my face
i pulled my hair
i clasped my hands over my mouth to keep
from screaming
cats has broken me and i've never felt
happier
a puntastic rotten tomatoes critic's
consensus reads
despite its formidable cast this cat's
adaptation is a clawful mistake that
will leave most
viewers begging to be put out of their
mureer sea
so that's cats jaclyn mark
is cats now and forever or someday will
it be a distant
memory he had to
had to first of all slack jawed
fascination let's give it up for mr tim
ryan and
give it a shout out to angie within this
this was not like planned like we record
these with tim early so i just love that
you're in here and we also pulled your
quote
but let's save talking about that along
with all of the other
just ooey gooey greatness that is this
movie uh in movie talk so
brian let's head on over to movie talk
[Music]
this movie starts so early
in my like thought process with it
because i believe
mark if you saw it when i saw it you saw
it at comic-con
2018 when we were like sweatily mixing
with people without fear
of a pandemic-style virus that's when
the cat's trailer premiered
it was like july like literally right in
the middle of comic-con
is when that trailer premiered and that
was sort of the first
i think visual representation of what we
all thought was maybe gonna happen
when you hear random casting like james
corden
and taylor swift and jason derulo
mixed with judy dench and and like
you're like okay what what are they
doing here
so i'm just gonna go ahead and ask you
first
mark when you first saw the catch
trailer and then i'll ask you angie
i have no memory of this dropping around
comic-con
i i remember people buzzing about the
cat's trailer but my memory of it is
actually in the rotten tomatoes
office in socal and
lucy in particular producing lucy being
so excited about the trailer she's
singing the music
and she was just so pumped for it and i
just remember looking at it and being
like okay i know right now
this is not gonna be my cup of tea but
i'm probably gonna have to watch this
movie at some point
i didn't know that i would get to
postpone that viewing for a couple years
but then
ultimately i have no recollection
of this trailer during comic con but man
i really
if i was doing stand-up that night i
can't believe that i didn't do my due
diligence and writing jokes
talking about the cats trailer yeah you
didn't
it was july 18th which i believe
yeah like that's either like the
thursday or saturday of that uh
uh angie what about you when did you see
the catch trailer
and what was your initial thoughts i
don't remember like the exact moment
that i
saw it i remember it dropping online and
everyone had like
a field day on twitter making fun of it
or just being like
omg wtf uh what i remember is a couple
months before that i was at cinemacon
and you know like the different studios
present like all the upcoming movies
they have coming up and we were very
we were very very much hoping that cats
would drop something they did not they
dropped like a little sizzle reel where
the actors were like oh cats is very
important and
it's very innovative and exciting like
one of those but then we just started
hearing weird things like oh the cats
are going to be cat-sized so the sets
are going to be humongous there was all
this talk of like digital for technology
and i remember
just being like i mean at the time i was
like this is probably going to be
disappointing and it's probably going to
be more like
boring than i think it's going to be but
you know it was fun
it was fun to think about and imagine
yeah okay so i guess i'm the only one
that i i very much remember when this
trailer dropped because
this was what it was first of all tom
hooper like people like think of les mis
now as like this great thing because it
won a bunch of awards and it was like a
big blockbuster
that was not a beloved musical a lot of
people had
issues with it and especially some of
tom hooper's i would say more like
questionable choices like filming it
live on set and having these like crazy
in-your-face close-ups to make sure
people know like oh yeah they're really
singing live
to the point where the tony's made fun
of it the year that neil patrick harris
hosted talking about like oh
tom cooper close-ups here we go i
watched this trailer
probably 15 times the day that it came
out
because it was like
and and i will give a shout out to a
friend of ours and a friend of the
podcast
andre the black nerd he did a reaction
video to cats
based on my recommendation and i'm gonna
go ahead and call him out for this
because he was at comic con and you know
with there's a lot for folks in the
youtube space to do at that time but i
told him i was like hey i know this is
not in your wheelhouse
but you need to do a reaction video to
the cat's
trailer and basically how he opens that
video is how i thought of it
which is he opens it where he's just
like oh what
wow and that was it like
his reaction to that moment in the
trailer is pretty much mine which is
surprise
curiosity and then shock and awe
and then laugh and that was basically it
and mostly because of the off-putting
cgi
like the heads moved in the trailer like
in the trailer we saw
this is not finished and not only is it
not finished it is so not finished i am
very concerned that they will ever
finish
um so it was one of those moments and
that happens a lot you know the first
aladdin trailer didn't really look as
good as it
would look but man it was
it was so questionable and i just
remember being like
how are they gonna try and make this
look real
because the first thing i thought is
someone who's actually a fan of the
musical cats is
this is ill-conceived and and that was
basically where i went
um from there because i remember the
casting news i went from like happy
to like pissed off like throughout the
casting news and then the trailer just
solidified me to be like
oh this is gonna be bad and i can't wait
to see how bad it's gonna be
but i couldn't believe the casting news
when i was looking at the cast i was
like
this how is this movie possibly going to
be bad
because look at everybody like no dame
judy dench and
idris elba and ian mckellen they're not
going to sign on to something that's
going to make them look ridiculous
right you would think i mean did you
think cass was good angie yeah i was
like were you excited about the cast
disturbed
i remember it mostly just being like
with every new announcement it was like
are they just picking names out of a hat
like it felt like when you have like
friends over and you're playing like
that game where you put celebrities
names and hat then you just kind of pick
random ones because it was just like
like who what why yeah
i i really think because it's cats
and because it has the potential like
universal does know how to do musicals
they're about to do wicked they're doing
the madonna movie which is going to be a
musical they're doing dear evan hansen
like
universal knows how to do that
but i'm just so concerned with just this
idea of them thinking that this was
going to be a good idea because it's a
difficult
concept i mean angie have you seen the
actual musical
like did you how much cats knowledge did
you have before this
not very much like in the months leading
up to cats coming out like i
had learned more about it because it was
in the news all the time but i had never
seen the
stage musical oh and mark you had none
well the one that i don't know the music
though i was very familiar with the
music particularly memory just because i
i heard
it's it was like seriously my mom and my
sister loved playing
particularly the music from cats and
phantom of the opera i guess we were a
big
andrew lloyd webber household well
is that mean that i'm august ahead and
ask you this when you go to the movie
was there a scene like when you looked
at it
that was a musical adaptation that you
particularly
vibed with i mean i think it's fair to
say you were not about this one
but no and and the first musical number
i i thought kind of fell flat for me
but i did enjoy some of the ones the
more comedic ones
i thought were actually pulled off
pretty well my favorite
musical number probably in the whole
movie is when we get to the jellicle
ball
and we're about to maybe see who gets to
go to the
what is it the heavy side layer and um
and taylor swift's cat shows up
and she has this cool song and dance and
everybody gets high on catnip i'm like
this
is this is what i paid to see and by the
way
i did pay to stream this movie and this
is the only time i'm ever going to
invoice rotten tomatoes
for the fee that i pay because i am now
the proud owner of cats on a streaming
service
oh wow yeah i own it anybody y'all want
to come over come on over let's have a
cat night
i don't need to i also own it on itunes
yeah
i do as well i think we all do because
we all had to watch it around the same
time
and it's not available for rent like
they're basically like oh you want to
see this
you need to buy it i don't blame them
don't hate the player
on this one because that is some great
game right there
real quick though angie is there anybody
who you
particularly felt in the cast was like
the top and the bottom and then i want
you to talk to me about which scenes
make you say to people
you have to see this but first who's the
top in your casting estimation and who's
the bottom
like who does the best yeah like who's
your favorite cat casting
in this movie and who's the worst um
let me think i think that ian mckellen's
number i think
actually like genuinely works like he
puts a lot of like soul into this uh
into this this song about a cat who is
thinking back on his life and i was like
in this moment it really clicks also ian
mckellen
really commits the man licks water out
of a bowl and like rubs up against poles
so like he is one of the actors in this
movie that's just like yeah i'm going to
be a cat i'm going to do it full-on
not going to pretend that half-assed or
pretend i'm above it
so uh he worked he worked really well
for me um
and then the worst i think james
corden's whole thing in this i i was not
a huge fan of
yeah um i will agree with you on that
with an honorable mention to rebel
wilson
i'm sorry um i was gonna go rebel
i liked gordon's look i thought he had a
cool look for a cat because
part of the the problem with this movie
for me is just being able to figure out
which cat is who
after a while and so the ones that were
more distinct i think i
i resonated with those more so if you're
actually asking me my favorite cat
i'd probably say old deuteronomy just
because
i it was so fun to see judy dench in
that role but i also got to give a shout
out to mccavity because
it just i like the that character it's
just cool
it's shrouded in mystery and you're not
really sure what's going on what what
his mo is and
it's idris elba so it's probably gonna
be good um
now the scene for you angie what scene
do you think
if you were gonna say to someone pull
this up on youtube this is why you need
to see this movie what is it
it would depend on if i was trying to
convince what i was trying to convince
them of if i'm just trying to say
look this movie is so bananas you need
to like watch
right now i feel like a good a good
start is the rebel wilson's
big number uh the jenny any dots one
not because i think it's like the best
number in the show or anything in the
movie or anything but because i was
watching when i remember being in the
theater and watching it and just
feeling myself become unmoored from
reality because like
she's like there then she like opens
this curtain and there are these like
mice that have the faces of human
children which is like kind of
horrifying
then there's all these cockroaches and
they're dancing and she's eating them
and then at some point she
unzips her skin and there's just a whole
other skin underneath and
i remember just watching then just being
like i am losing my mind
again i must have taken drugs today and
not realize it because surely nobody is
actually feeding me this movie
so that was a that's that's what i would
show someone if i wanted to just be like
look this movie is bananas and that's
why you need to watch it
[Music]
now for the icing on the cake why did
you want another jellicle line i can't
keep being in this kitchen but i think
that i think the number that actually
works the best is
gimbal shanks is just straight up so fun
it is the best number i think in the
whole
movie um i agree with you even though
they put pants on a cat and didn't
explain why he was the only cat with
pants
like that's still to me i'm like i guess
they needed the pants so that he could
have the shoes because it's a tap number
but he's the only cat with pants yeah i
saw
someone point i saw i saw an article
where someone pointed out that i guess
this movie finally answers that question
that debate we were having about how
dogs wear pants
whether it would be on all four legs or
just two of them and
uh katz does finally i guess answer that
question
yeah i just thought it was very like i i
sorry i thought it was very european of
the cats
to just be be cool with being naked
but if you want to express yourself and
wear something then then you're cool so
i just think that they're more
progressive
than humans in that way because you know
you sometimes dogs are walking you
occasionally see a dog with a sweater on
and
and the other dogs aren't like hey why
is this one wearing clothes they're just
like hey
nice sweater man let me smell your butt
then they move on with their day and i
think that's what
i i totally and i also did not even
like have any thoughts that was that one
cat wearing pants i was just like ah
cool that was exactly what i thought
lucy go ahead oh sorry
i just i just wanted to say really quick
to skimble shank scene i think it's the
one scene in the movie that's actually
better than the 1998 video production
version
it's so good and the tap dancing is i
don't even think they do that in the
1998 version so i was like holy sh this
is amazing
sorry yeah i just love cats i had to i
had to say something no no i
i agree with you i would put that one
close to the top
um i would put mccavity's number
before he opens and you see idris elba
in brown fur that makes him look like
he's really weirdly naked
his number was great up until then but
as soon as he did that i was like
what and angie your scene is actually
the one where i'm like
so when i saw cats i
did then they did the like social
reaction i called it a catnip
soaked fever dream that is visually
laughable
but i could not look away and the
scene that makes me think of that is the
jenny scene
where she skins herself and there's skin
underneath like this is like a rupaul
wig reveal that you did not even want to
think about seeing
in addition to that there are black
women cockroaches
like dancers and these are black women
and they are dressed like cockroaches
and they like and it's like who thought
this was a good idea
and the children mice it was uh it was
the borrowers
meets like secret of the nim i literally
was like if you were sober watching this
movie
you were missing this movie yeah i
respectfully disagree you don't need
drugs to watch cats
oh i am not a dairy kid is already
like being on drugs oh no i yeah i
agree with angie's point i'm not saying
you don't need it i'm saying that
there is an entire movie you are missing
being sober watching this yes but you
have to get to the right state of mind
you got to be very
careful with with how you use herbal
medication
if you're watching cats because it can
mess up
your dreams that night it can penetrate
your mind
and not let you out and i
yeah i watched this sober and
for the most part i did have to crack a
coors light at one point but
it was i i don't know that it would have
enhanced my viewing of it either way but
also give a shout out to
like the most emotional moments for me
were were jennifer hudson's cat
singing even though i was wondering if
that's real snot or not i i thought that
it was just such great that is what
the only tinge of emotion i actually
felt watching this movie was
it was grisobelda grisabella
yeah why the cats have such complicated
names because they're jealous there's a
whole song about that yeah
all cats have three names etcetera
etcetera etcetera you should watch the
movie then you'd know
yeah i should watch the movie with you i
i think we need to do like a watch one
we need to do a virtual watch long now
that we all own the movie
we can go back and i can walk through
what i missed
i will say this um god i can't even
believe i'm saying this though
the musical of cats itself
is bizarre and has had this weird sort
of broadway
dominance it was for the longest time
the longest running broadway musical
but it's it's weird it's just weird
there's no real explanation
and i think it was sondheim went to
andrew lloyd webber and was like oh i
get it now
it's this allegory about homelessness
and da da da da and that's what this is
and we're really trying to make it
an allusion to heaven and da da and
andrew lloyd webb
was like it's just cats mate and like
that's it
like he's like it's just cats like he
has put no thought process
into any of this other than cats dance
and do a show
and so i think if you could just get
lost in that aspect of it you could
enjoy it but let's be real people made
fun of cats the musical even though it
was beloved
even though it had some hits that people
liked
a ton of broadway people looked at it
sort of like
the mcdonald's of broadway hits it was
one of the first really sort of like
commercial you came to the town to see
broadway
when broadway switched from being this
very
only elite people could see it it was
their version of the movie theater and
it sort of changed and to be part of the
tourist experience of going to new york
cats was a big part of that switch is
that
is that the play or is that the broadway
show that got android weber sort of that
reputation of being the
the the mainstream broadway
guy i mean i don't know because this was
not
his first it was early but it wasn't his
first i think this
made him more of a populist composer
yeah i will say that whereas in like
yeah there's people that knows steven
sondheim and they know
what he's done but i don't know i think
there's a different level to it
there's always a different level to
everything what other musicals has he
done for those listeners
in nebraska who may not follow
i just know the opera that's it this is
ages of the opera
um let's see jesus christ superstar
is his debut he did a vita he did
um starlight express sunset boulevard
um i have seen phantom and i've seen
jesus christ superstar on broadway so
i got some i got some artistic
credibility and
my favorite from his filmography deep
blue sea the musical
um is that a shout out to our expert
researcher mark hoffmeyer is that
a shout out that is a real thing and it
is a shout out to mark hoffmeier because
he did do that
um wow school of rock he also did the
school of rock musical adaptation which
i think is his last one that
he produced and he's a lord in the house
of lords
um he's like it's it's a different he's
a different kid
you know what i'm saying anyway i think
this is really funny because
uh tom hooper directed the danish girl
which won
alicia verkander and i believe
also eddie redmayne oscars was nominated
for several
and his follow-up film is cats
and i just there's just a part of me
that will always be like
okay this is the guy that did the king's
speech i was gonna say
i love love love the king's speech
and i love what he did with it and i
love his directorial choices in this and
i think that
when you watch this movie i don't know
how you felt about it angie but it's
almost like
tom hooper knew he had one choice and
he's like i'm just gonna lean into the
craziness of this i'm ju
and i can't i can't meet the audience
halfway i have to go
full nuts with this movie i agree that
he went he like really committed which
is one of the things that i love about
this movie
is that there is no sense that these
people are like kind of half-assing it
but i actually feel like one of the
things
that makes cats the movie so strange are
all the choices that they
uh made to try to make it seem more like
stayed and respectable like the fact
that they were like no
like we like we don't want people in
like costumes that would be crazy we
gotta we gotta be
we gotta make this look respectable by
employing cutting-edge digital fur
technology and having their ears like
twitch around and like stuff like that
and like all of that i can see how i can
kind of see how you're like oh i'm gonna
i'm tom hooper i want like another like
les mis type hit i'm gonna
try to do that make it seem like very
real and whatnot
but like watching it that's exactly why
it feels so
bizarre that's what launched it right
into uncanny valley
yeah um i wanna i wanna make sure we get
a chance to talk more about the pantheon
of of cats on screen and also a little
bit more about
uh tom hooper but i do want to add
this one to it as well which is that
this is
more about movie musicals there's
several movie musicals that have been
like
put on the list of like you can't make
this into a movie
west side story based on a play has a
story with three arcs that's very easy
to turn
into a broadway musical but but cats
and prior to that chicago were both
thought to be somewhat unfilmable
in a theatrical format for a bunch of
reasons but the main one being
is there very much to the audience
speaking to the audience productions
and the way they did it with chicago is
they put all the musical numbers in
roxy's head which sounds brilliant now
but when rob marshall did that it was
like
i think tom hooper thought that he could
do that with this he thought that he
could like
make it real and so therefore make it
good
and that was just like the dumbest thing
i've ever seen before but i'm i'm just
curious do you think it could have ever
been done
accurately like as a stage play angie
and people would have bought it like the
way they bought maybe les miz or
other music movie musicals that people
have like liked and not made fun of
i mean it's hard for me to personally
imagine
how that would be done of course i'm
also not like a
you know big director where that's my
job so never say never
i feel like uh animated for example
probably would have been a much easier
sell in a lot of ways with this movie
because it's so wacky
um and i was actually just thinking i
was i was just talking just now about
how like part of what makes cats so
weird is all the choices that it made to
be respectable and
i kind of feel like if you had handed
this over to someone who was more
committed to like no i
i like to you know just be i want it to
be like completely bold and completely
crazy like if they were trying harder to
make it crazy it would almost be
less crazy yeah like the reason why it's
bad is because they tried to make it
good
barry alla the room uh mark
this was not your cat's movie but
what's your what's your top cat's movie
like what what cat movie do you look at
and you're like all right i got you
my top movie that is featuring cats of
some sort
would probably be another movie that
relied heavily on cgi and that would be
the jungle book the disney version of
the jungle book it's got tons of cats in
it
and they're walking around and they're
talking
they do maybe a little bit of humming if
not full-on singing
but i agree with angie i think the only
way you can make cats
the broadway play into a movie musical
is
to do it animated because and that's the
only way that i think that
audiences would take it seriously which
sounds ironic because people sometimes
associate animated movies with kids
although they are for everybody
but it's it's the same thing with comedy
like you can get away with so much more
in the world of animation if you're if
you're the simpsons or family guy as
opposed to
what you can just get away with where
that wine is where you're pushing the
envelope live action
and sometimes it just doesn't translate
well which is why i'm so curious to
you know talk to people who have seen
the broadway play and it's like
what was it about this i know that it's
wacky on broadway too but
how is it the longest running show of
all time
i guess it's because people love
watching the live
aspect of it they love the live singing
and dancing of it because the
the choreography is great but i think it
just
it's like well yeah but you got you know
30 takes to do it
in making a movie i want to see it live
once
done done well all right uh what about
you angie
top cats movie you're a cat owner i am a
cat owner so my
my actual favorite movie involving cats
is every time i videotape or
you know film them on my iphone uh but
my favorite movie involving a cat like
any movie involving a cat
yeah like or cat you know yeah i think
that's okay
uh one that comes to mind that is not
like this but is
i guess you could call it a musical
inside loom and davis guy carries around
a cat for a lot of the movie
oh actually that is a good pool and the
cat is a
very um intricate part of the storyline
well not intricate but very
he helps move the story how about that
yes
yeah yeah he's like an important figure
in those good cat movies out there
life of pi has a really cool tiger and i
really like life of pi
um but i probably would actually redact
the jungle book because as much as i
love both versions of it
milo and otis the adventures of milo and
otis they're just a dog and a cat
and dogs and cats like each other well
they do in this movie kids because they
got to survive together
it was it was homeward bound before
homeward bound
and it's better than homeward bound that
movie is so good
actually yeah i'm with you on that one
so my favorite cat movie
is um the movie in which i knew that
this filmmaker was going to do great
things uh and that is mr jordan peele's
keanu
him and kian peele did keanu that
premiered at south by southwest
and like the the indie film kid in me
would be like watch ketty that's a very
good cat movie and like you know that's
very high brow but seriously keanu
first of all that cat is adorable and
they put him in a thug necklace with a
hat
and so that right there makes him
amazing but my honorable mention
is the texas lawyer with the cat filter
from earlier this year where he was on a
zoom
and he didn't realize that he had a cat
filter on and he was like
i'm here um i'm not a
cat oh my gosh
i remember that that is the best that is
cinema
in motion
oh i'm gonna treat myself yeah you gotta
check this out it is literally
probably 30 seconds that will
automatically make you giggle and if you
can make it through the video without
smiling you should seek help immediately
because someone has stolen your soul
real quick before we get out of here
there's so many bizarre things about it
like jason derulo who literally is a
thirst trap in motion
making him unsexy dame judy dench
doing cat like leg lifts
in a fur coat so i'm just going to get
you guys to just give me your like
bizarre last thoughts that that you're
just like
how how did they make this into a movie
and then we'll we'll go ahead and do a
little bts but and angie i'll start with
you
any any just like i can't believe this
is in this movie but it's in this movie
uh well basically the whole movie the
first time i i've seen it several times
at this point but the first time i saw
it i remember being like this is
like in the first few minutes being like
this is very weird these cats look very
weird surely though like you know it's
like a two-hour movie i'll get used to
it and then just by the end i still was
like no these cats are very strange no
matter how many times i see them
and then the movie ends with that um
with judy dench's number
the cat is not a dog one uh which is
already which already as i'm describing
it sounds like very bizarre because
you're like so judy dench is a cat and
she
sings about how a cat is not a dog but
that's not even the weirdest part the
weirdest part is she sings that
directly to the camera so you are
watching this whole movie you've been
watching like all these cats have their
little like jellicle party
and like you know introduce themselves
and do all the stuff and then suddenly
like just as you're like okay i guess
the movie's over i'm gonna like
wrap up and get out of here like judy
dench just looks straight
at the camera straight into your soul
and then starts
talking to you about what you were
supposed to have learned which is mainly
that a cat is
not a dog which sure i mean that that is
a true fact
and then not only that but it also just
that song also keeps going several times
after you think it's finally over
so every time i was just like wow this
is nuts okay i'm gonna oh we're still
going so that that that i think is just
the perfect way to finish off this movie
yeah and with the other cats basically
staring at her in the weird way you
would
like yeah we have to look interested and
you looking at nothing
uh mark what is your you know cat's
moment
the one that illuminated it the most for
me is when
i believe it's the tap dancing number
and they're all dancing on the train
tracks
and that just highlighted to me in big
bold letters that they have no idea what
they're doing with the aspects
of the cats or how big they actually are
because sometimes the cats
seem big like they're human size other
times they seem like they're not even as
big as a mouse and so
it's just all over the map and that one
i'm like i just don't think this works
[Music]
by that point if you're really if the
biggest
issue you have with this movie is that
the cats don't
stay the same size all the time you're
probably watching the wrong film
yeah um i will say for me
the part that i was like oh oh
why uh was the fact that when
i saw it at the junket and
this is a little bit behind the scenes
but it perfectly sort of segments in
that
i saw a version that was not finished
and i saw this
two weeks before the movie was supposed
to hit theaters
and then i found out later that they did
not actually finish this movie
until the morning before the premiere
like that's not cutting it close
that's just insane and for me that
the only part of the entire movie that
ever looked finished
was the song with jennifer hudson and i
came to find out later
that that is the reason why that one
looked the best is that was actually the
test footage that they showed
to universal every time they were like
hey
how's the movie coming along they'd be
like we got this
and they basically did like a bernie
madoff with the studio and be like look
how well this is going
look at how well this is going and that
section
if you look at the movie is the best
looking section and you're almost like
off put by like why does the rest of the
movie look so
bad in comparison that was their bait
and switch
and they just kept showing them better
versions of that scene
and then they just kept hoping that the
rest of the movie would follow along
and it never did to the point where they
actually sent versions of the
movie to theaters that they had to
recall
because like significant portions of it
still showed like green screen
so yeah i was gonna say did the movie
ever actually get
finished because i don't know that
that's true i know that
taylor swift's scenes were finished she
as a cat was finished yes yeah basically
there were
certain moments they kind of got
finished and the rest were crap
all right last thoughts is it a
cult movie so bad it's good just
good just bad like um mark i'll start
with you
where do you put it i don't think it's
so bad it's good i also don't think it's
just a complete
horrendous mess that no one should ever
see i think this is the very definition
of a modern
cult film i'm not gonna call it a cult
classic that's for the
society to decide the next you know
coming decades but
i feel like this is a movie that like
rocky horror picture show or anything
else
you can get together with a bunch of
friends and go to a rowdy late night
screening
and have a lot of fun celebrating
slash mocking this movie and with this
that
that venn diagram is very overlapping
with having a blast watching it and also
just
lampooning it the entire time i agree
uh angie where do you put it
i echo most of what mark said i mean
before the pandemic
shut down movie theaters it already it
seemed like this film was already on its
way to becoming like a cult movie
because there were all those like rowdy
screenings and all that stuff and it
uh and one of the reasons why i so
fervently enjoy defending this film is
because like sure
it makes a lot of very bizarre choices
that like you know
people like people would be like that
that that makes no sense this doesn't
look good like what's happening here
but like it's also a movie that uh i
have a great time i had a great time
watching it everyone that i've watched
it would seem to have had a great time
watching it people
love to talk about this movie and i
think all of these are elements that
point to something more than just like
it's not just oh this is a
this is a bad movie and we you know
whatever we can forget about it like
it's a movie that
maybe you think it's good maybe you
think it's bad maybe you think it
transcends those notions which i feel
like is kind of where i have settled
uh but either way it is a it's a movie
worth talking about and you don't always
get that i think that's i think it's
special in its own way
uh for me i guess i would say again
about the same but i call this an
internet movie this is a movie that the
internet
birthed just stated and gave
everything to it and took everything
away as well
but this is a movie of the internet and
the internet is part of it
and that's just the way i like to think
of it and so if you're the type of
person
that you know maybe wanted to do the
cinnamon challenge or stuff like that
like this movie you're gonna find a
place for it in your heart because it's
a movie of the internet
and if all of those things sort of pass
you by you should leave this movie alone
but that's where i will put it in its
recommendation if you are one of these
people that loves the absurdity that the
internet can bring
you will be down for it and that's
saying something considering a movie
called
zola which is literally a movie that was
given birth through the internet is
coming in theaters but until that moment
happens cats uh
cats will reign supreme all right that's
it for our movie talk section
we're gonna go ahead and go ahead and
talk a little behind the scenes but a
little different this time we're gonna
do behind the scenes
trivia so brian q so
[Music]
okay mark i think you have this one
right you have our trivia questions
i have some amazing trivia questions as
written by
producie lucy because she knows a little
bit more about cats and the franchise
and the broadway play
then do i but i did have an inkling as
to what a correct answer might be for
this first
question if you two are ready andrew
lloyd webber who we've been talking
about is
the proud owner of an egot he's got a
emmy
a grammy an oscar and a tony award
can either one of you name how many egot
winners
there are how many there are how many
well i know some of the names don't say
the names yet
just try to guess the total amount of
egot winners
needed oh i'm bad at i'm bad at this
kind of trivia uh well i'm bad at all
trivia
i think that i know four composers
okay one actor
one songwriter one actress
yeah i'm going to go ahead and say 12.
okay angie i'll just i'll do over under
with you do you think it's over
under 12. i was actually going to guess
12
so uh now i guess i will go
under i would have gone under two the
answer is 16. there's been
16. so now the next question i'll start
with angie angie can you name
two egot winners that are not named
andrew lloyd webber
no
i'm sorry i'm so bad at like awards
trivia then my mind just goes completely
blank
did the frozen composers get get that
i believe so that's a possibility it was
the lopez
the location and technically there's two
of them
so there you go there you go so now i'm
going to make jacqueline uh
give me two egot winners uh john
john legend and whoopi goldberg but also
rita moreno
also the guys that wrote uh
alan menken uh
the guys that wrote uh hairspray
mark shaman and what's his name right
i think jacqueline knows her stuff i we
were looking for
mel brooks was the correct and mel
brooks that's the other one yes
i did know mel brooks but those are the
only ones i could think of here's a very
here's a very fun one
that is more what we're talking about
today because somebody from the movie
cast of cats
was originally going to be a part of the
original broadway production
but they snapped their achilles tendon
a week before the play-out so i know
this one
i do know this one too go ahead angie oh
judy dench
she was gonna be isabella right she was
going to be grizzabella
and angie gets major points
for that one yes one of the reasons why
she signed up to do the movie
and probably bullied ian mckellen into
it do you think she would have sung as
well as elaine paige who ended up
playing her
i mean i don't know but
judy dench was was that for the broadway
or for the west end version
let me know i think it was for the west
end version because i think that's where
it debuted because it's andrew lloyd
webber yeah i mean it was the
like original original yeah yeah so i
think that's western cause elaine paige
ended up um
taking her place and then played that
role for a hundred years
yeah all right one big trivia question
left and unfortunately for angie it is
another uh
number question and this time it is
about the awards that cats
the movie won but we're not talking
about the oscars we are talking about
the razzies how many razzies
were taken home by these kitties
four oh i'm guessing uh
i'm gonna guess you know i'm gonna guess
hi i'm gonna guess eight
all right you two are gonna be great
friends because you should meet in the
middle
and go right to six yeah i actually have
another one more question that i think
would be fun for us because we were
talking about tom hooper
and his many works prior to
this um movie and i
won everybody's take on who they think
what movie they think is
the highest rated according to rotten
tomatoes tomato meter
of tom hooper's career it should be the
king's speech
okay my guess is the king's speech okay
um there's a movie that i don't think
i'm gonna count because it's called
longford and i've never heard of
it and it only has seven reviews but
it's a hundred percent so congrats from
2006 it might be a tv draw i'm not sure
what it is but i do know that
the king's speech rightfully so is
sitting at a certified fresh number of
drumroll please 94
on rotten tomatoes and that movie did
really well at the box office too so uh
good for him
good for tom hooper uh that one was a tv
movie
longford okay well tvma
didn't come out in theaters technically
it doesn't count
yeah yeah and that is that is your cat's
trivia for today kids
use it wherever you work with your
family with your friends
impress everyone you know with your
knowledge of how many razzies the movie
cats won
exactly six razzies
including worst movie including worst
movie and look
this is the thing i actually said um
which is true cats was the best comedy
of 2019.
period and people were not ready to
understand and hear that because they
were actually
comedies in 2019 but cats was the best
comedy in 2019 and i will hear no other
debates and i don't care that it came
out on christmas
it's the facts all right that's it for
trivia
we're gonna go ahead and go to the
mailbag
brian take us there please sir
okay back to the mailbag and from a
member of our beloved ketchup crew we
have sebastian
moreno from el salvador i shout out to
you sebastian for
emailing us he says hey mark and
jacqueline sebastian
from sebastian from el salvador big fan
of the podcast and each time you guys
talk about any movie you make me want to
re
re-watch those movies especially the old
ones
so just like you guys i had the
opportunity
to see if it changes my mind of what i
thought of the movie when i first
watched it well we're putting you to the
test this week buddy seriously
i i feel for you sir if you if you go
out and get cats because that is
commitment as we've said
in that spirit we would like to uh i
would like to hear
you venture into another movie ranking
for rt is wrong
like when you did the harry potter
movies i would like to hear what you
think of christopher nolan's movies
he is my favorite director and i do
think tenet deserves
much more love than what it's getting
ooh
i don't know if we could do the entire
nolan filmography but but revisiting
tenet is something to be said because
that movie
that movie has baggage like the fourth
time you've dated somebody
it really has a lot to it wow
yeah it does experience in dating
somebody
four times to my knowledge i also don't
have experience in finishing tenant
because i put it on twice
and i fell asleep now in my defense or i
guess the movies defense i was pretty
tired both times and it was later at
night so i'm not going to blame tenant
for that but
it felt like a lot of thinking was
required on my part so
i'll just go ahead and say i still think
my favorite christopher nolan movie
is the one that saved us from bat
nipples batman begins
i think is still my favorite really see
i'm gonna go even weirder my favorite
nolan movie is the prestige
it's really good yeah like he put david
bowie as nikola tesla which is probably
some of the greatest casting to ever hit
cinemas what about you angie you got a
favorite nolan movie
uh i am gonna go with inception probably
but about tenet i will say i have seen
it twice i enjoyed it both times but i
actually
somehow managed to understand it less
the second time and i don't think it's a
movie that you can so much understand
his experience and in that sense
it's a lot like cats i guess yeah you
don't need to understand it you just
need to experience it
hey look i also give it up for him for
tennant it's the first movie where he's
had a starring poc
i hope that's a trend he keeps going and
he casts elizabeth to becky and allowed
her to wear heels
any time those two things happen for any
director
i'm happy i think we have a great
challenge for for angie
and her great work at mashable is maybe
uh to try to do an article
that is syncing up cats with tenant and
like why they're basically the same
they both have people just kind of
showing up and saying things to you that
you're just like i don't know what
you're talking about that doesn't make
sense to me
and the costumes are interesting i will
say every suit
that robert pattinson warren tennant
is something that i would like to see on
him more often
oh yes sure i'm also telling myself in
the sense that i've only read
articles about the costumes and of tenet
i've not actually seen the movie
you are so on brand for who you are
jacqueline
i wrote it in i read an in-depth article
spread in gq about
all of the suits and tenant but i did
not watch the movie but yeah look kids
if you're enjoying the podcast
jacqueline is just here until the met
gala calls and says hey we need a new
coordinator
we're hiring you because that is really
her dream gig
and and when she gets it all i want is
just to be able to walk that carpet once
in whatever i'm wearing that day i mean
literally that is only why i'm here i
don't love movies
i am trying to get a gig in fashion
that's it uh
me and angie are gonna make it happen if
you actually knew what me and angie were
on a daily basis you would find the
comedy of this entire conversation
mark dresses up more often than i do
angie ma'am
thank you so much for being here today
it was a true joy
but um tell us folks what you're working
on
obviously they can check you out at
mashable but what's new over there and
what else you got going on
uh yeah you can find my work on mashable
you can also
hear me about once a month on kpcc's
film week which is a radio show like an
old-timey radio show not just a podcast
um and you can find me on twitter to
yell about cats at ajhan
oh i love that also we also like to ask
everybody that comes in here for a
recommendation
movie or you can do tv if you want to
but preferably if you got a if you got a
movie record for us
oh i was told i'd have to answer this
question and then i just completely
forgot
uh so i'm really sorry
um this is not exactly obscure but i
guess i will just go with tenet for now
because we were just talking about it
and it's a movie that i
it i think it is his it is his uh it is
his dumbest movie and i mean that as a
compliment
it is not trying to be more than it is
it's a great time
awesome well then i'm gonna go in here
and say that uh netflix has a doc series
called high on the hog
which talks about how food from africa
migrated become african-american become
african-american cuisine
which then became american cuisine and
if you ever want to learn about the
various parts of the pig that we eat
check out this movie it will make you
hungry but it is
really really dope high on the hog
netflix i would
recommend that one it's really good like
and then you like want to go like
eat the food like you want like when you
learn about the story of mac and cheese
you will never look at macaroni the same
never um anyway thank you again angie a
big shout out to mr
brian perez i want to give a shout out
too to producey lucy welcome back i'm
glad to be back
mr mark ellis you did such a good job
while i was gone i heard your
your love with naz and then also last
week with thor
the dark world uh you guys have been
awesome it was uh
sad to be gone but glad to be back
and again please email us
subscribe to wherever you listen to
podcasts and please rate and review we
want to make sure as many folks get a
chance
to listen to this podcast and next week
i really think folks are going to be
excited mark what do we have for next
week
we are getting into the world the
cinematic universe of
it could involve dinosaurs at one point
the fast and the furious and the movie
that we are
taking a closer examination in that
great franchise
is tokyo drift which happens to be
as of me talking about it one of the i
think three
fast and furious movies that i have not
yet seen and so i am very excited
to watch tokyo drift particularly in the
context of
f9 opening up and i'm also really
excited to see into the heights i
haven't seen it yet but again i can get
swept up in the world of musicals
so i am looking forward into the heights
oh you should absolutely see into the
heights i've seen the stage production i
have now seen the movie twice
and if you could still be surprised if
you've seen
the first one with the second one and no
secret here i love
anything that lin mo miranda does but
he's a musical genius and he will be
probably the next egot winner we see
so there you go kids okay he's gonna
beat those kids from
uh from the greatest showman if it's the
last thing i do
all right guys thanks again um you can
find me
at that jaclyn you can find him at mark
ellis live
angie you can find at angie han and uh
again
thank you all for listening and we'll
see y'all next time bye
[Music]
you